- [Voiceover] The amount
of money that farmers
in Massachusetts paid
to maintain their crops
between 1991 and 2008
is modeled by the equation above,
where P is the amount of
money the farmers paid,
in millions of dollars,
and t is the year.
So this is how much they
paid in millions of dollars.
T is the year,
but they're saying assuming
1991 is t equals zero.
What does a 3.53 mean in the equation?
So let's look at this.
So in 1991 when t is equal to zero,
this whole term is going
to be equal to zero,
and the farmers are going to pay.
P is going to be 100.
So they're going to pay
$100 million in 1991
to maintain their crops.
These are all the
farmers in Massachusetts.
Now as t increments, each
time t increases by one,
the amount that the farmers pay
is going to increase by 3.53 times one.
So one way to think about is this is
the rate of increase from year to year.
As t goes up a year,
the amount the farmers
pay is going to increase
by $3.53 million.
So let's see which of these choices
are consistent with what I just said.
The cost for maintaining crops
was $3.53 million in 1991.
No, that's just not true.
In 1991, this term is zero,
and it was $100 million.
The cost for maintaining crops
was 3.53 million in 2008.
No, that's not going to be true either,
because it's 100 million in 1991,
and then each year it's going to increase
by 3.53 million.
The costs for maintaining crops increased
a total of 3.53 million
between 1991 and 2008.
No, it's going to increase
3.53 million per year,
not over the entire time span.
The costs for maintaining
crops increased by
3.53 million each year
between 1991 and 2008.
That is exactly right.
Every time t, and we go forward a year,
t increases by one,
it's going to increase.
We're gonna have 3.53
times that one higher t,
so we're gonna increase
the whole P by 3.53.
That kind of rhymed.